I don't know why it's starting to laggy
that's no weird
welcome back I haven't been in the scene
forever I can't believe in Julia's
hosting a good thing that came out of
this quarantine is she needed her job
back so yeah I need some money right I
told you you're never leaving oh you'll
make a lot of money but you just might
not want to do it that way yeah fans get
mad views Julia Sean under the beard no
I was gonna make only fans just as a
joke and it was low just gonna be videos
of only fans like fan appreciation I
just see how many people signed up for
it all right so today we're gonna be
talking about am I the [ __ ]
oh my favorite reddit kind of thing
mm-hmm so am I the [ __ ] for charging
rent from my dad but not from my mom my
father and his family lost her home and
had no place to live his he has a
teenage son
my half-brother who is 15 and a known
smoker because they had nowhere else to
go
I offer them to stay at our house we
usually rent out to other people the
house is situated within our property
just next to our home so it's a separate
home that they've got the raining out
yeah okay but it's like right next dam
what kind of ballers are they like a
duplex mm house prior to my dad moving
in my mother and my sister moved in with
us six months ago after my stepdad
passed away O'Shea we have many spare
bedrooms in our home so them moving in
wasn't a problem this is where the
conflict arises mm-hmm I don't charge
rent for my mom I don't let her cook I
cook for five people in our home which
is my husband my mom my toddler and my
sister it's just my way of looking out
for my mom because that's what she did
for me when I was young and struggling
she raised me as a single mother for
years
my dad has a problem with this because I
am charging him and his wife the same
rent I charge other tenants it's a well
furnished house
he thinks I'm playing favorites between
parents because I don't charge my mom
any money he thinks he should pay less
rent as compared to other tenants
because I'm his daughter apparently he
doesn't like to be reminded of the fact
that he charged me rent the one time I
was very sick and had to move in with
him and his wife when I was in college I
had a part-time job and struggled to pay
my bills with my illness I wasn't
showing any consideration what he also
has a problem with my husband oh sorry
you know he also has a problem because
my husband doesn't help him out with his
groceries he's older now 71 and thinks
we should be the one getting him his
groceries well you know I knew it or
like oh [ __ ] we don't think so his wife
is a prince mm-hmm what is 50 and he has
a young son they gave me going doing the
grocery shopping if he's so fragile to
move around
am I the [ __ ] no yeah she gripped
without him to apparently right she's an
[ __ ] in a good way
like she needs to be an ass this guy's
an [ __ ] he sounds selfish yeah yeah
but also at first I was like this isn't
general gender-equal because she's not
just she's not she's not cheating her
dad the same way she's treating her mom
but then we found out that but the back
story is like okay she lived and was
raised by her mom yeah a single mom is
wish we first heard yeah dude I mean if
he was paying child support I get it but
if you it sounds like he's been a
deadbeat did you hear how she's doing
the some of the smoker for no reason
just sit there like a exigence a like he
smokes up the house you can smell is
trash everywhere no no I mean that's
like saying he's been a lifelong wine
connoisseur yeah son would litters maybe
she went to smokers and maybe she's like
I'm making an exception for him because
I don't want it to smell so highlight
the fact that her dad deadbeat
his 15 year old son to smoke he's 15
yeah okay yeah
yeah everybody years old his wife is 15
his sons 15 yeah what do you say his fed
just died yeah I knew it yeah that's
good no this guy's a dick and then he
charged her when she was sick
yeah yeah I mean if he charged her for
rent she can charge him for rent but
what if he's like it was only one mom
for six months you think what but that I
moved out that's why [ __ ] it is kind of
weird though to charge family full price
no [ __ ] that Joe he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he charged her rent [ __ ] that if
anything she should make it more
expensive so that he doesn't hurt his
liberty he's got friends and family I
would charge just the mortgage like a
break-even rate even if he didn't like
them well if I didn't like him I
wouldn't even tell them to come I'll
leave him on the streets
I'm very all travell responsibility no
she felt nice not to let him stay there
because he could've got right anywhere
else then that somewhere in between
she has he has a [ __ ] summit smokes
yeah I don't know I would have been like
you didn't take care of me when I was a
kid so [ __ ] you and find your own place
to live but that's that's just how I am
but say then say you said [ __ ] you to
that your parent right but then would
you still if you let them live on your
property would you charge them cheaper
even though you don't like them but so
you allowed them to live there
Oh would you talk I allow someone to
live on my property I like them oh so
you got one end or the other nothing in
the minute this way I like my dad it's
not that I don't like him but I don't
want to be in charge of what's happening
if he can't pay rent or whatever he has
a person that he was a father figure to
and I'm all like that's who should be
responsible because there's just that
time that you spent together but I don't
hate the dude but to me I don't feel
responsible
and it's almost as if like that's like
you're in her situation like there's no
filial piety or no no I'm worse than her
because she feels that she's give she's
still giving him a place to like ran out
and stay and all that stuff I wouldn't
even offer it I'm like I'm trying to
make money [ __ ]
i'ma go and get somebody else to stay or
I will give it to like if you if one of
you guys are down and out right I charge
you the mortgage so I just break you Wow
Meah I've known you that long you're not
gonna how bad is it
are you like Joe I had to open up only
fancy I mean it's bad enough where I
want to live with you you'd make a
separate property though I crazy well in
that case you could live in the doghouse
and Bart and Tiger could live in the
real house no I mean like yeah I think
it's fair to charge just the mortgage to
friends and family because it's a
break-even right but if they're really
down in mountain they can't even pay for
the mortgage and I know that they now
I'll be like yeah [ __ ] until you find
a job but if it's six months and you
can't find a job I'm like all right dude
what's going on yeah to you you can't
get each other his wife can work his 15
year old you can work up a damn ball you
know to Mila you can work at the
cigarette shop yeah I worked at 15 like
it's easy to find a job you know ii mean
that's three possible incomes right
there to actually yeah people are just
aren't hustling enough that's that's
what i think they easy i mean what i
like about this is that the dad is
complaining about all these things but
she still doesn't want to move out he's
entitled dude he doesn't know what
[ __ ] what mess he's created a little
part of me though is like this is so
cool that this chick has a heart and
even like through everything she
explained like clearly she's not the
[ __ ] but my [ __ ] she's just inviting
drama in turn house there's a reason why
they're divorced right cuz she's living
with her mom so the moms in the house
yeah and that second family is right
next to them in the property and the son
smokes and then the dad is fighting with
the daughter cuz she's not your paying
favorite I get it though like you feel
that responsibility to your parent even
if you like didn't really know them
growing up right you're just like the
fact that their blood you're like I
gotta at least do what the smallest
thing I can do which is give them a
place but they have to pay for it
I'm like I get that mindset I don't
think I would just be like bro I'm just
gonna give you a lump sum of cash go
away
you're even giving money though because
I have a heart but what does they come
back I'd be getting paid from the house
so like you get the to them once and
then they're gonna come back again you
could try to come back and then I'll see
where I'm at at that point in my life
but hopefully I could be like nuh-uh
go away is that why I don't have people
asking me for help because you go go
away don't you give alpha NATO's okay so
I have a I have a family member right
that called me for support and they're
like I want to run away with my lover
and I need your support and I said I
don't support this [ __ ] you money
supporters they want emotional support
they want me to back them up in their
story and then they wanted me to send
money exactly they're [ __ ] delusional
weird and then I told them you know in
order for you to do that I said you got
to do it my way you got to come clean to
everybody first and foremost get
everybody involved you have to listen to
everyone's opinion and you have to go
through the shame of what the family
might do to you or say to you and then
you know because I love you I will
support because you did it honorably but
if you just [ __ ] run away and make
the decisions all by yourself
I can't I'm enabling a criminal in my
mind
you don't mean that's why it makes sense
yeah I don't feel like good with that so
then they're just like well I thought
you have my back and you you you believe
in true love and [ __ ] like you know be
do you know if this together yeah
they're together they're there they're
out in a pic and strawberries and [ __ ]
together I'm just like man you [ __ ] you
that's [ __ ] weird that's like a job
or as a hobby romance I'm very close to
this person like that's how I can be I'm
close to them but I also won't violate
my morals in order to harbor that kind
of like move look cuz you love them
enough to talk to them straight and
that's I think with everyone yeah that I
think everyone should be I think in this
case she should tell her dad like you're
a [ __ ] selfish piece of [ __ ]
hooking you up you know I don't know
maybe not in those words but yeah I
guess she might have to it like some
people need that though some people need
like very like strict direct wording to
get a point across cuz like in the sense
she's being his parent now that's true
you know she's the one that's
complaining he's the one that's like I
think even with her son back like
talking [ __ ] to her [ __ ] husband
though if you're up front up with people
like this like they're still not gonna
believe it they're not gonna take it in
well I think she's hopeful that she can
like rekindle some sort of relation I
mean like she gonna be hopeful but I'm
saying that the dad will never learn so
yeah 71 death was a dumb [ __ ]
stubborn donkey dude I mean I'm only
saying this because apparently there's
some like family should I had no idea
that happened but oh you wait till now
to show this hey I'm just trying to find
the right time y'all okay yeah so um I
found out that like so this person is
not blood related to us but also [ __ ]
that man yeah exactly
so I'm a face but apparently he gambled
a [ __ ] ton of money away and my cousin's
husband was the one that pretty much
took him out of debt and like it was a
lot of money like maybe like half a mil
every Asian family has like a gambling
somebody that's like he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he was like oh cool mana debt kind
of deal let me do it again he's filled
the man oh my god
still demand things from them you know
but like he he like leaves with them and
stuff but like I don't think he asked
for money to gamble anymore but I'm sure
that he still has that tendency though
like yeah yeah it was a real piece of
[ __ ] and I was like god there's a reason
why I'm not close with you yeah I think
people that rescue other people yeah are
just as bad because they're enabling it
like you didn't suffer the consequences
of his debt so now that you know your
cousin's husband or whoever when they
clear that [ __ ] yeah it just they let
that [ __ ] free but whatever whatever
saving a life though it could have been
a life or death situation was there like
bad bad like that that can't happen
you have to get rid of his restaurant in
order to whoa no he gambled he gambled
on his restaurant and lost the
restaurant and so he was in debt and so
my cousin's husband got him out of debt
because you know he's smart he's good
with money and like he works really hard
and I think the only reason why he
enabled that kind of behavior is because
he loves my cousin's so [ __ ] much and
like they're so close knit out there
that like he would make that sacrifice
for and that's why emotions ruined every
story we've all learned something
[Music]